I'm Sonic a little ball of super energy
in an extremely handsome package on my
planet people were always after my
powers so I came to yours it gets a
little lonely I can't with that guy are
you hiding out in my garage if they
steal my power they could conquer the
universe you have to help me Louie no
please it's life or death
good morning my royal chum mr. dr.
Robotnik I'm going to give you five
seconds to tell me where it is
wait don't hurt him
Rhodri Brooke this can't be happening me
oh my god stop back alright yeah what
the world's largest rubber band ball we
gotta see it no this is not some fun
family road trip you're right it was
lame gift shop let's go though
whatever this creature is I'm going to
uncover the source its power
[Music]
I just thought you might like a latte
with steamed Austrian goat milk of
course I would a lot of take I love the
way you make them without a lay low let
me show you how it's done so super get
outta here yeah time to go I always want
to do this
how are you not dead I have no idea that
was an illegal left by the way why would
you throw your life away for this
silliness of a lien good time is my
friend let's go
[Applause]
my power
and I'm using it to protect my friends
so you're supposed to be Tom's best
friend that he won't shut up about well
I don't see the appeal
[Music]